uh MythBusters obviously everyone knows
[ __ ] videos
Okay so this was during the watch time
okay so this was the original Adams
Family TV show from the 60s I was
wondering why I was in black and white
yeah so this is on the 60s this is this
was this was during a time where I had
this like weird obsession with watching
a lot of old films so I would like this
was during the time where I would be
like so uh was Citizen Kane actually a
good movie I'm gonna go and check it out
right so I would watch like citizen it
was okay I would I would watch Citizen
Kane and like all the you know the all
films and like all of the [ __ ] this
is how you started your altar phase yeah
I was yes
I was like I'm not like those other kids
watching Breaking Bad [ __ ] off I'm gonna
watch Amazon you mean let's cook Walter
but
um yeah I think what really was cool
about Adam's Family like the even though
this is [ __ ] what a 60 year old show at
this point yeah it's still [ __ ]
hilarious you know whenever you like you
know you watch Modern TV shows that pop
on the TV you're like oh [ __ ] Whatever
Whenever you for some reason in a place
and old TV shows come on they're always
so good yeah they are I don't know if
I'm like crazy but like that was just
funny they must be good in order to have
still to still be still survive yeah
right yeah maybe it's like Survivor bias
of like well yes because you're seeing
the best of the best that we remember
right yeah cherish and made sure we kept
in HD I'm sure out of every one Adam's
family there was 20 really oh yeah of
course but yeah like I mean what is
Adam's Family about I I just know the
name Adam's family is about comedy is it
a drama it's a comedy so Adam's family I
think it's based off comic book series
or a book or something please confirm
Kai but basically it's about this really
[ __ ] weird family called The Adams
Family uh that are like very like
Macabre and like obsessed with like
death and stuff like that and they're
just like a very weird they were like
the original like we don't like the
other families type of family right
um yeah so there's like Gomez and like
Morticia and uh [ __ ] I don't know
Uncle Fester and like just characters
like that where it's just like you know
there was just like it was the weirdest
cast of characters they're human right
yes they're human but they're but
they're so weird and so obsessed in the
Macabre that they're almost not human I
mean there is a character that's also
not human but in other another
interpretation of the show they are
actually like yeah why do I think
they're vampires yeah other in other
versions of stories like the I think
Adam's family is I think it borders on
like are they human or are they just
weird humans or are they non-humans
trying to live in a human is he is
oh a cartoon okay is it public domain I
can't remember if it is I don't know to
be honest but they've done re a bunch of
remakes of uh like movies from like the
90s Adams Family movies is [ __ ]
hilarious and I think recently uh Adam
Sandler one right not uh
Adam's Family one or is that a Dracula
movie
I don't know
what's the one that Adam Sandler's in
the Adam Sandler animated cartoon am I
crazy am I mixing
yeah so like what I really enjoyed about
the show is that like it because the
characters are just so [ __ ] absurd
yeah it makes for some really really
unique comedic bits right um so like for
example like
um I don't know like uh Lodge for
example is this like almost like
Frankenstein's monster type of thing but
he's also the he's also the butler of
the family right and then there's also
another character called thing which is
just a disembodied hand that just crawls
around and emotes and there's been so
many remakes of it I think there's gonna
be a remake of there's like a new like
Netflix I think TV series based on
Wednesday Adams oh uh which is like the
youngest daughter of Adam's Family
something made by what's his name Adam I
thought maybe my brain was dumb until
Adam Sandler was in it because it's The
Adams Family yeah that's all about to
say but yeah
I thought we I thought that was like too
obvious
yeah but it's a real if you want like a
classic like funny like comedic uh show
then I I'd say Adam's family's still
like a lot of the episodes I think are
still really funny yeah did you ever
watch a thing too yeah oh yeah of course
what is it you know it oh okay oh okay
that's it that's it yeah did you ever
watch the Twilight Zone since yeah oh
yeah Twilight Zone I grew up with as
well but like I don't think Twilight's
always one of those shows where that I
would see it every now and then on TV I
wouldn't like religiously watch it like
Simpsons have you ever watched that TV
show that was like fact or fiction
and what all the memes of that that guy
going like it's it's a lie I made it up
it's it's not true I made it up I lied
you know I think so that sounds like
[ __ ] dude what God damn it why does such
a [ __ ] passion oh no no no no wait
wait I know what you're talking about
the guy in like in the Smoky room in the
Smoky room no I made it up yes okay no
now I know what you're talking about I
didn't know I think so I thought what I
didn't know that came from like a TV
it's uh uh beyond belief beyond belief
uh Jonathan
Frakes Beyond a belief I thought I don't
know I don't know why I just thought
that was like a History Channel show
yeah I thought so too yeah it's just
like a bunch of oh yeah and realized
you'd forgotten where you parked your
car ever gone mountain biking what do
you want to be when you grow up what's
the right tip have you called oh yes
yeah yeah this one's good I like that
show that was really good yeah
MythBusters I think we spoke about this
a little while ago yeah I mean I met
Adam Savage is great MythBusters is
[ __ ] awesome if you don't know what
MythBusters is Jerry take it away
MythBusters basically Adam and Adam
Savage and Jamie Hyman uh they are
basically I think they used to work in
like Hollywood as like special effects
uh creators but they basically have like
two guys with really long science
backgrounds who basically take common
myths and scientifically prove whether
it's real or just a myth yeah um really
simple concept but because they go about
it in a scientific way it's really cool
to just see them be like all right so
there's the myth for example that yeah
um there's the myth for example that
like uh enough balloons can pick up a
human body off the ground yeah so then
they go out and go all right how many
balloons would it actually take to pick
up an average human body off the ground
and so they would go through all this or
like you know another one was like um
how many layers of uh of glass could
stop a bullet yes for example there's
also like you know can salsa dissolve
prison bars yeah yeah just like stuff
all like all like uh uh floss like a
teeth floss yeah can it cut through a
steel bar for example it's so it's like
they basically take common myths or like
stuff you see in movies and they go is
like is that Capital fact it's like uh
you know the the predecessor it's a
crazy YouTube engineering Channel yeah
obviously I was going to say this did
science YouTube before science YouTube
yeah yeah absolutely it's very it's very
uh it feels very nerdy yeah and it feels
very you know doesn't care if you don't
like the show or you don't like the
style it feels like they just wanted to
make the show and make it for them yeah
and make it the way they wanted it and
blow stuff up yeah it was it was one of
the few shows that managed to make
science cool oh yeah because whenever we
think of science engineering we just
like [ __ ] fall asleep because like
why why should I give a [ __ ] about
chemistry or boring or like you know
[ __ ] sorry
the reason we give about chemistry is
breaking that's right but but now oh
you're telling me that chemistry can
blow things up and set things on fire
okay suddenly I care now just like like
in a lot of in a lot of the episodes
what I really enjoyed is the fact that
it was just purely Adam and Jamie just
being like
what if this would happen or like have
you ever thought about could this be
real like a one that's really good is
like um shell shock from grenades how
close like it's the uh the myth of like
if there's a grenade about to go off and
someone Dives on top of it then that
will save everybody else yeah and so
what they would do is they would like
add a ballistics gel that would create a
human shape thing they would put it on
top of a grenade they would put another
human some distance away and then they
would see if that human turn dies yeah
and it was just funny because it was
just an excuse for them to just blow up
a bunch of grenades I mean it's funny
because you you started those the soft
being like you know what they did it for
the name of science you know they want
to blow [ __ ] off yeah I was just like
talking to the safety third guys I'm
like I just realized they just find like
the most convoluted reasons to find to
find a reason to blow [ __ ] up you know
that's true and that's that's
MythBusters yeah basically honestly and
so like oh you know a lot of like I
[ __ ] watch the show religiously it
was like my favorite thing to watch it's
a great TV show oh it's fantastic very
well it's fantastic yeah um edit Nanny
[ __ ] goes without saying probably one
of the best Cartoon Network shows to
come out I just love editing a lot I
love the um I've got the name of the uh
this art style where the the every
character's lines are always moving oh
that's like like a rubber hose no no
rubber hose is more like Disney like
right oh like 30s animations yeah it's
like it's like a it's like boiling lines
or something yeah I love that the color
palette of edinetti oh yeah nuts I mean
and like just it's one of those shows
that where I feel the original creators
were just like what's human anatomy yeah
that doesn't exist well tell us about
the surgery what happens Ed and Eddie's
basically just a Cartoon Network show
from the 90s where it's just two
thousands is it 2000 that was the 90s
for sure it's two thousand I don't know
it's somewhere around there though early
2000s where it's basically just based in
a cul-de-sac in everyday America and
it's just a bunch of kids just [ __ ]
doing random [ __ ] in the cul-de-sac to
try and get jawbreakers so try and get
jawbreakers so they do a bunch of
schemes to try and money to get your
they love these draw breakers for some
reason and they'll do anything yeah and
it's great every every character is
great that it's just fun show the voice
acting is so good yes it aged really
well really really well the animation
style is so good there's a there's a
clip that recently I found on YouTube
that I've just been obsessed with again
and it's just this one episode where uh
Eddie uh this guy in the middle here if
you don't know Eddie is like he he
dresses up as like a demon uh like
character to try and convince Ed who's
the dumb guy to do a bunch of weird [ __ ]
so that he could like turn him into like
a freak to like earn it a freak Show and
there's one scene where he's just like
eat your mattress and then edges looks
at the bed and he's like okay
and then it's a double D this little guy
Ed comes in and it's just this scene of
just Edge [ __ ] eating this mattress
hole and it's the most like okay before
it was yeah it was just like good Lord
man he's just eating this mattress
um it's just the most absurdist humor
ever but it's really really [ __ ]
funny like one thing that like
re-remembering Ed and Eddie makes me
realize is that are cartoons as weird
now no no
a little bit a little bit different way
yeah because I feel Eden Eddie kind of
falls into the same genre of cartoons as
like you know the ramen the The Ren and
steam yeah they're running Stimpy where
it's like so absurdist to the point
where it's almost gross where the art
style can be gross at times oh yeah yes
yeah well I was just I'm just thinking
about it I'm like man I watched a lot of
weird [ __ ] as a kid this era of Cartoon
Network had some of the weirdest
television programs oh yeah like Cow and
Chicken was another one where I'm just
like oh Cow and Chicken
like these shows are [ __ ] weird well
like if you put this on Adult Swim it
would totally just blend in oh
absolutely and I'm just like how did we
grow up with these cartoons that's so
[ __ ] weird what yeah I like
re-watching some scenes of edit Nanny
I'm like how did I not get traumatized
with some of the [ __ ] I'm seeing right
now like dude yeah I would not show my
kids did you ever like an Ed and Eddie
friendish kind of group Vibe uh yeah I
kind of did
um I was definitely like the the Eddie
type of character where I'm just like I
was just convincing other people to do
dumb [ __ ]
that makes sense yeah I definitely had a
friend who was like in yeah anything I
told him to do he would do I think
everyone every friend group had an edge
yeah but that's the thing that's what I
think that's what I think was so good
about ednetty was that it was such an
absurdist like completely just like out
of the norm type of show but the
characters fundamentally were characters
that you could recognize whereas like
there was at least one character in Edd
and Eddie where you're like I have a
friend who's like that or I'm like that
um music as well oh did an intro opening
song